if you have police department that has a
kind of militaristic minds that has a
you know us versus them sees the people
they serve as potential enemies not you
know citizens with rights you know it
doesn't matter what kind of gun they're
armed with you're going to have problems
I am Nicholas be for reason TV and today
we're talking with Radley Balko he's a
journalist blogger at the Washington
Post late of The Huffington Post late of
reason has also worked at Cato Radley
thanks for talking to us my pleasure
welcome to Nashville yeah you will
explain what you do you write for The
Washington Post but you're based in
Nashville right as I work for you well
actually I lived in DC for ten years and
didn't get hired by the washington post
until i moved away which i always find
amusing but yeah I work here I've cover
you know criminal justice issues civil
liberties issues but kind of out of the
national focus so there's no really no
reason for me to be in DC so yeah I work
remotely it's great I like it do you
actually have do you have staff meetings
and stuff like that nope I don't think
I've had a meeting since I started you
do you even read the Washington pack I
do read the washer oh I read online I
don't actually don't get the paper
delivered but yeah obviously I read it
online and you know when i'm in DC I
always always read it obviously starting
with your work at the Cato Institute
where you wrote particularly a study
called overkill that was about kind of
the rise and the the ubiquity of
militarized policing and no-knock raids
and rates gone wrong you worked at
reason for a number of years and wrote
stories in that vein went to the
huffington post now at the washington
post what is your sense we are living
now in a world where the issues that you
had laid out more than a decade ago are
really in the forefront reform efforts
are starting I mean do you do you feel
like things are going in the right
direction or are we missing the boat on
what's going on I think I think the
discussions moving in the right
direction I mean I think people are
finally paying attention to these issues
and people are finally a little more
skeptical of this kind of stuff I
remember writing in the book riesel
warrior cop about a raid that was like
broadcast on network TV in the early 90s
where the clinton ministration had just
introduce this policy of zero tolerance
of drugs in federally funded public
housing remember there was this raid was
really violent and you know their
children ever it's thrown to the ground
they find this tiny little bit of pot
and you know you thought you would think
it would be sort of embarrassing for the
for the police because they you know it
was all all these guns all this
commotion they find this a little bit of
personal use of marijuana and it was
sort of celebrated on the news is like
you know like fine yeah I finally we got
these bastards and you know they're
gonna that are all going to be evicted
you know and it was like you know as a
single mother and a few kids and
probably one of her friend their kids
friends pod or and I think today like
you show that I think people be angry i
think that video would go viral people
be really upset about it and so it would
be used as a point against the police
rather than a celebration of we're
taking back our cities exactly but I
think policy-wise you know I don't think
things are getting all that better I
mean I think Obama did a couple of kind
of important symbolic passed a couple of
important symbolic policies you know
limiting what kind of gear can go to
police departments from the military and
you know made a lot of sense I think
they're already reconsidering it there's
a lot of backlash from police groups
we're not and it's clear that the police
themselves online and whatnot right
where they you know would they take
their head cam footage and stuff like
that and put it on well I think they're
much more reluctant to I think they do
kind of know you know what they are
aware of the the bad optics of these up
kind of operations and particularly when
they don't find anything or particularly
for nonviolent crimes I mean the idea
that they're still kicking down people's
doors and you know shooting dogs and
throwing people on the floor and
gunpoint over a you know a drug that's
now legal in what three or four states
is you know it's absurd but it does
still happen it definitely still happens
people are still getting killed in these
raids do you you you had talked about
the kind of policies from DC based
policies that were giving essentially
surplus military hardware and software
and everything to local police
departments how much is the technology
driving policy I mean is it that police
start looking like soldiers so they
start acting like soldiers or is it that
they are thinking like soldiers and
that's why the
getting this stuff on I think it's both
ink boat each drives the other I mean I
think they're and I think it's also it's
useful to think about the police
militarization issue that way I think
there is the issue of the gear like is a
grenade launcher appropriate and
domestic policing you know is an MRAP
appropriate domestic policing but more
than that I think that the mentality is
is really more concerning than even the
gear you know gear is sort of except for
maybe a grenade launcher you know a
Taser is a pretty innocuous thing it's
the policies the government it's it's
how it's used once it's in operation and
if you have police department that has a
kind of militaristic mindset has a you
know us versus them sees the people they
serve as potential enemies not you know
citizens with rights you know it doesn't
matter what kind of gun they're armed
with you're going to have problems well
you know it's interesting in the in the
2016 presidential election for the first
time really since the 90s crime as a
national it's a presidential issue
Donald Trump has announced again and
again that he's the law and order
candidate he's calling to mine Richard
Nixon in particular in the late 60s and
early 70s when crime was really rising
to historic levels Hillary Clinton of
course is known in the late 90s or in
the in the 90s talked a lot about super
predators her husband was tough on crime
that's how he showed he was a different
type of Democrat what is the reality of
crime in America now versus say 10 or 15
years ago and are we are we acting as if
there's a crime surge when there isn't
or are we actually you know are people
like Trump and some urban mayors and
whatnot when they start talking about
holy cow you know crime is coming back
you know what what is going on and how
should we be talking about this in a
more productive way so crimes been
dropping for about 20 years violent
crimes and dropping for about 20 years
there has been a bit of a leveling off
and then a bit of an uptick probably in
the last two years it's still you know
the uptick still puts us at where we
were and say 2011-2012 so it's not as if
you know crime is sort of spiraling out
of control you know if it is going back
up again it could be something to worry
about it could also just
II crime wasn't ever going to continue
declining 20 right and at some point
there's going to be leveling off and it
could just be statistical noise there
are cities where you know we are seeing
massive spikes and violent crime and
that's concerning but I think there are
explanations are localized explanations
for that talk a little bit about you
know why did in your estimation and you
know criminologists are kind of all over
the map and a lot of them are like you
know we don't really have a good
explanation but why do you think crime
from the mid 90s declined so much
overall but especially violent crime and
then you know what what are some of
those local issues that are driving it
up in places like Chicago you know it's
probably the best-known example you know
why crime drops as you said there are
lots of different competing theories I
mean the ones those I found most
convincing is some probably some
combination of rising standard of living
just kind of general standard of living
I actually think there's I've seen
convincing arguments that removal of
lead from like paint and drinking water
may have had something to do with it and
then just an aging population if you
look at sort of the graph of when people
commit crimes it's always in late teens
to about 28 29 or and it drops off
dramatically do you think you know I
think we totally agree that it's over
incarceration but you know locking up
more and more people of that age is that
also part of the reason why crime went
to study that I've seen it puts about
the incarceration about 10 is
responsible about ten to fifteen percent
of the crime drop so it you know it
wasn't insignificant but you know crime
also dropped dramatically in Canada for
example of the same period and they
weren't locking up people at nearly the
rate we were so again it's not exclusive
but he had to contribute absolutely so
then in places like Chicago which again
the murder rate is and the total number
of murders much lower than it was at its
peak but it's it's up a lot from over a
couple years ago what you know what are
in what are some of these local
conditions that are giving rise to so
there's a great book called American
homicide by Randall Roth who's a
historian at hio State University and
one of his theories that I find pretty
compelling is this idea that if the
citizenry believes that the government
is illegitimate if they think that if
there's a not it's not even a matter of
trust in government as a matter of trust
of doubting the government's
gintama see you see homicide rates spike
so now if you look at the places where
we've seen you know large increases in
homicide over the last couple years
you've got you know Baltimore we had a
mayor is indicted not too long ago you
had a policy throughout the 90s of just
mass arrests where you know the Justice
Department report on the police
department last year was when the most
skate actually earlier this year
scathing and blistering that I've ever
seen you know you can make a good
argument that there's not a whole lot of
faith in the sort of legitimacy of
government there same thing in st. Louis
you know I wrote about the sort of
predatory nature the municipal courts in
st. Louis I think it's 70 80
municipalities in st. Louis County and
it's a weird quirk of history and white
flight and sort of racist draw you know
boundary drawing but basically because
of all that you've got this county where
you know there are just dozens and
dozens and dozens of little
municipalities you can drive down a
10-mile stretch of the highway and say
in Lewis County and drive through 20 25
different cities and each of them has
their own police force and you know
serious crimes are investigated by the
st. Louis Police Department of the only
job of these little tiny police
departments is to generate revenue to
keep their governments afloat and to
keep paychecks coming and so basically
it becomes this this antagonistic
relationship between the citizens and
the police with the cops just they just
look for things to write people up for
and if you yeah as you said if you get a
fine you don't show up to court then you
get an arrest warrant there are counties
and municipalities in st. Louis County
where there are five or six seven
outstanding arrest warrants for every
person that lives in the county so you
can see you know that's that's clearly a
jurisdiction or license country where
there's very little faith or trust in
these sort of legitimacy of government
same thing in Chicago you know Chicago
Police farm is notoriously corrupt
shadow government's notoriously corrupt
so I find it to be a pretty fascinating
you know possible explanation for this
it's kind of out is the solution to that
then I mean how do you Rilla gitam eyes
government is like actual reform and
kind of broom sweeps clean type of thing
or I yeah I mean I think it very I think
the the prescriptions would would would
vary based on the city
in st. Louis County they just need to
eliminate a lot of these municipalities
there's just no reason for them to exist
I think you know Baltimore I you know
revamping the police department I mean
you're obviously never going to solve
sort of corruption in government but you
know you can't have police departments
that aren't you know as antagonistic
that don't have arrest quotas that don't
do you know warrant or they come warrant
sweep so they're just going to you know
go and do these massive sweeps and
entire neighborhoods and just look for
people who have outstanding warrants so
yeah those kinds of policies policies
are more oriented toward you know I'll
give you a good example here in
Nashville we have actually have a great
police chief here some people might
disagree but a couple years after he
took office he'd pointed out that I
think it was two out of every three
times one of his officers pulled
somebody over they got a warning and not
a an actual ticket which you know it's a
good thing but then his philosophy
behind it is what was really sort of
encouraging which was that you know said
it's the job of the police department is
to keep the roads safe it's not to
generate revenue for the city and I
think changing that you know outlook
that kind of philosophy that cities
should not be relying on fines and court
fees you know as a line item in their
budget do you think Barack Obama has
been overall has he been good or bad for
kind of crime and its intersection with
race relations I mean I think Obama has
in some ways been kind of revolutionary
and that he has said things that no a
sitting president has ever said before
and Eric Holder you know as a sitting
attorney general said things things like
know that just acknowledging over car
over incarceration of the mass
incarceration is a problem that it has
devastated you know community certain
communities in the u.s. acknowledging
the the sort of injustice of civil asset
forfeiture that it's often unjustly
applied you know just the very notion
that president would say something like
that the militarization issue that said
you know most of the most of the the
revolutionary aspects of his
administration have been about saying
things and not necessarily doing things
and not
I actually implementing policies to kind
of back up those now he has done some
things you know the reigning in the
Pentagon giveaways again that was kind
of symbolic because at this point most
police departments get their gear
through the problem Homeland Security or
through donations it's not you know the
Pentagon's actually plays them played a
huge role in getting its getting the
trend started but it doesn't contribute
a lot all that much anymore as far as
race relations you know I don't know how
qualified I am to comment on that in
certain ways it was always going to be
bad because I think there's a certain
segment of the population that was never
going to be happy with the black
president no matter who it was let's
close by talking about the stakes of
election 2016 obviously you're you're a
small l libertarian so do you have
somebody that you are voting for in this
election and you know that's kind of the
to flip your personal bias but then is
there you know what what are what what
is the best outcome for the issues you
care about things like criminal justice
reform things like you know getting
police into a better place with with the
populations that they that they help
surveil so i'll be voting for gary
johnson again and I you know don't no
qualms about that at all as for the the
Trump versus Hillary of anything I'd
actually I've been quoted in the
magazine is saying I think they would
both be terrible but I think Trump would
be catastrophic I think Hillary would
just be sort of just another terrible
president for criminal justice issues
and specifically you know I mean Trump
is basically telling us how terrible
he's going to be on these issues so I
don't think there's any reason to not
take him at his word on that you know
Hillary Clinton has a bad past I think
she has you know decided that it is now
politically safe for her to you know
embrace some of these issues how much
political capital she's willing to spend
on it who knows I mean she's also very
divisive figure so I could see her
trying to push these issues causing you
know the Republicans in Congress to sort
of double down and and just for the sake
of opposing or I'm not particularly
optimistic I think most of the really
significant change in criminal justice
reform is going to come at the local
level not even the state level I think
it's gonna come in cities and Charis if
we're starting to see criminal justice
reform become a an election issue
da's races in sheriff's races sometimes
even in you know state legislature races
but we've seen lots of district
attorneys so the last couple years
actually go down because you know their
history he hadn't Anita Alvarez in
chicago the get the estate in the
prosecuting Cleveland lost after his
decision than Tamir rice case so we're
seeing the you know I've always thought
that that was kind of the missing piece
in the criminal justice reform movement
is that there was no political activism
and if you're a in one of those
positions one of those elected positions
there are lots of people are going to
vote for you because they see you as too
soft on crime until there's sort of a
political penalty for overcorrecting
there you know I don't think we're going
to see any change so that's been a
really encouraging development well
we'll leave it there we've been talking
with Radley Balko of the Washington Post
late of reason Bradley thanks for
talking to us my pleasure for reason TV
I'm Nicholas